women who accuse Jeffrey Epstein of
sexually abusing them when they were
underage say they still plan to seek
justice despite his apparent suicide the
disgraced financier apparently killed
himself in a federal jail in New York
City over the weekend Epstein was
accused of running a sex trafficking
operation and abusing dozens of teenage
girls the Justice Department is now
investigating how he died and why no one
prevented it mola legi is outside the
jail where Epstein was held mullah good
morning what are we learning
well good morning Tony the medical
examiner's office as you know perform an
autopsy on Epstein's body yesterday but
says they're waiting for more
information before drawing any
conclusions source tells CBS News that
Epstein hanged himself inside a jail
cell here at the correctional facility
which as you can imagine is raising a
lot of serious questions about how
exactly he was able to do that remember
it was just a few weeks ago that Epstein
survived a previous apparent suicide
attempt a representative for workers at
the Metropolitan Correctional Center
tells CBS News the death of Jeffrey
Epstein here is not a surprise
she says staffing is completely
inadequate with workers putting in more
than 60 hours a week
leaving them overwhelmed and not alert
it had been just over a month since the
feds announced Epstein's arrest the
charges allege that Epstein sexually
abused young girls by enticing them to
engage in sex acts for money in less
than three weeks after sources told CBS
News Epstein was found semi-conscious
inside his cell with bruising around his
neck the New York Times reports Epstein
was supposed to have been checked by
guards every 30 minutes but that
procedure was not followed the night
before his death in a statement Attorney
General William Barr said Epstein's
death raises serious questions he
announced the inspector general as
opening an investigation into the
circumstances surrounding it the
apparent suicide happened just hours
after the release of some 2,000 pages of
documents from a prior lawsuit including
testimony from alleged victim Virginia
goo Frey you're screaming on the inside
and you don't know how to let it come
out and you just become this numb figure
she claimed Epstein's former girlfriend
Lane Maxwell directed her to have sex
with former New Mexico Governor Bill
Richardson former Maine senator George
Mitchell in Britain's Prince Andrew
among others they've all denied the
allegations and none of them have been
arrested or charged with any crime for
all of the epstein victims it's going to
take a long time to really get their
minds around this Lisa bloom represents
several women who claim they were abused
by Epstein she says it's important for
others to come forward so that everyone
involved can be brought to justice
let's get to the bottom of this you have
nothing to fear anymore because Jeffrey
Epstein is gone legal experts say
federal prosecutors will ultimately
dismiss the criminal case against
Epstein but will continue to investigate
any potential co-conspirators who may
have helped him run its alleged sex
trafficking operation meanwhile
attorneys representing victims say they
will continue to file and pursue civil
cases against Epstein's estate Gail mola
thank you very much